but we're talking about the great
pyramid of egypt and we're talking about
something that's how tall is it do you
know
481 feet at its height which is i've
told this to other people before but you
live in arizona like me so you are of
course familiar with the chase tower in
downtown right yeah you know the tallest
building in arizona is the chase tower
it that i believe is like 483 feet so
we're talking basically identical so the
great pyramid would be as
tall as the tallest building in all of
arizona and not to mention 755 feet wide
at each of its bases and so when they
talk about like this ramp theory you
would literally because people have done
the math on it you would literally need
more stones or as many that made up the
entire pyramid itself and you extend
like a half mile out like because like
if you get to a point where you get ten
percent grade every physicist like
there's no you're not moving those 70
ton blocks up that so like okay so the
this is the consensus this isn't like
jimmy like guessing like this is like
okay well how did they do it 70 ton
blocks more than 120 of them uh you know
more than 300 feet up inside the
alleged kings chamber and all that
so it's like okay so if they did the
ramp theory which isn't um
that's not a bad theory at all like it's
like okay like if they're gonna get
these stones up there like i you know a
ramp theory is not bad but then you do
the math on it's like well if they
needed more stones or as many as it
would take to build up the entire
pyramid well then where are those stones
now and i could say well okay uh i use
those for the next pyramid cool okay but
then what where are those stones like
for that you know what i'm saying you do
next next next and i'm like
yeah no that's a that nah i
i don't know how they did it and i i
it makes me
i feel proud to say i don't know because
there's a lot of people out there that
say we do know this is how and i'm like
okay well that's there's no you can't
prove that so to say you know is that's
not honest also the outside of the
pyramids was smooth and shiny
perfect and perfectly smooth and shiny
it doesn't look like that now but it was
and also
there were tops to the pyramids so i'm
curious what you think
the top was made out of what you think
the purpose of the temple was and then
also just to like one final piece of
like
having been there and going through
tunnels and the yeah and the inside
pyramid the shafts and the stairs and
all that like everything on the inside
was definitely like i mean there's no
decorations it looked like it was meant
for acoustic purposes how do they carve
that into the stone how do they plan
ahead on that i think they probably had
to have some sort of like cutting not
cutting but like frequency
device that had to have been able you
have to go in after they had to have
gone after they had to run in after to
like carve the design
or add or something like that but anyway
give me your synthetic what the hell the
the pyramids are all about and what they
were used for and all about the top that
doesn't exist anywhere other than there
is one what's that called there's a
there's one top left i can't remember
the name of it right now but they
haven't that then they moved over to
them
the bin bin so of course we were all
taught that the pyramids were built to
be tombs for the pharaohs
and i really want to emphasize to people
that that theory did not exist until the
latter part of the 1800s at that period
of time britain controlled egypt they
quite literally invaded
they had authority there um
a lot of people don't realize that egypt
has been
absolutely conquered
at least several times like anything off
the top of my head but like who knows
the other lost history there
um so i just want people to know that
the only
there is absolutely no almost no
evidence to even suggest that the
pyramids were built to be tombs for the
pharaohs or anybody as you were
mentioning besides the fact there's no
decorations they never found a single
mummy in any pyramid ever which
surprises every time i tell that to
somebody i mean like oh you know i tell
them like i'm talking ancient history
and i mentioned that and they're like
really like yeah
um the internal structure and layout is
so utterly bizarre that to me i believe
that it was functional i do not think
that the pyramids were built to be tombs
and i know that sounds crazy to some
people first because like well what is
it
we mean functional like it's a stack of
bricks like we talking about
and i i just generally i'm just sharing
what i think i think it's above us that
they were some people back in time were
more advanced than we are today
although that's not to say that we're
not more advanced than them as well i
think that there's just different
realities that can exist at any point in
time in in in
like if you were to get a bunch of
humans and put them on a bunch of
different planets and come back
however many years later i would i'm and
assuming they didn't get obliterated by
the elements or whatever and just got a
chance to really just thrive you know
what i mean like they're fed and they're
secure and they're just allowed the
human ingenuity to to
carry on i bet you each individual
civilization would be doing
things that the other civilizations one
thing's possible and vice versa that's
what i think i think this is how humans
work
um and i think that's what happened back
in the day and i i suspect that the
pyramids were some sort of energy device
and i say that because the nile river
once went right up to it and i when i
think of like the largest structures on
earth today like hydroelectric dams
that's for producing electricity and
when you look at the fact that the nile
river once went right up to the steps
i'm like
and there's a subterranean chamber some
have philosophy or or suggested that
theorize i should say
that
it channeled water and did something um
and and
i don't know though like what i do know
is that i walked through it and knew i
was in the presence of greatness and
there was not a single thing about it
that to me
resembled a tomb because i went to the
valley of the kings i went through the
mastaba's all around the giza plateau
which are known burial sites
um and
there's not a single similarity at all
except
that empty those empty sarcophagi boxes
inside the alleged king chambers of each
so okay maybe they were
there's a few possibilities there either
they
later on were used to be kings for
somebody which is totally possible
um where those boxes were once something
else like in the in the king's chamber
it almost seems to me that that was
something else and then was carved out
because the um you went in the you had i
don't know of course you did you went in
the great pyramid king's chamber right
chamber queen's chamber and subterranean
did you did you lay in the box i did i
was going to ask that i did i l i toned
in the box we all did a chance yeah yeah
they're not wild for people who don't
know what toning is it's just honestly
like
do it
yeah like
it's just like sounds it's uh so anyway
we all had an opportunity to lay in it
and did you too i had
about almost three minutes alone in
there the great pyramid king alleged
king chamber totally alone
and it was like that was a special
moment for me because i was like i did
it i made it here like i'm here like i'm
like i was literally like i don't know
if i pinched myself but i remember
thinking like pinch pinched like holy
[ __ ] jimmy made it and not only did i
make it i'm there alone it was and then
i laid in the box by myself and i
remember just looking up and like and
one of the things that stood out more
than anything was the acoustics that
even the my breath the echoing i've
never experienced
sound reverberation like that right it
was next level insane because even if
you're having a conversation it's like
echoing i mean you know like it's like
but like at a level i've never i'd even
know could be possible it was crazy
and um
yeah i just i just knew i was in the
presence of greatness i remember looking
around at all the precision of these
huge 70 ton stone blocks that were fit
together perfectly without any type of
mortar
and and just thinking to myself like
what i knew i was confused in there i
was like i don't know what this is but
it's something else and nothing about it
i didn't have any burial chamber vibe to
it at all and i know some people listen
to this like okay who cares about your
vibe i'm like it just wasn't
i just don't i don't believe it i would
bet my i would bet
i bet a limb on it and if i end up
losing an arm in the process i would be
utterly shocked i would be shocked
because i i do
i genuinely believe and it's not just a
feeling it's like if you really research
every argument you can hear about the
pyramid on being a tomb and otherwise or
other theories as well that are
alternative
yeah i lean way against the the burial
thing i'm like now it's something else
because okay you know when you went you
go down so here's the thing a lot of
people don't realize that when they
think of the pyramids they in their own
minds because they're not familiar with
the layout
they assume or think that it was like
this maze uh to hide the pharaoh you
know the tombs and you know it's like
this complicated structure it isn't you
go down
and then you go up and then you're there
there's no there's no like zigzag left
and right where do i go from here like
no like if this was meant to hide
pharaohs which they claim i'm like well
then all i did is go down and up and i'm
here um but that part aside remember how
you went you you go down and then when
you get into that soap or you go up
excuse me you first go down then you go
up into the uh you get that grand
gallery excuse me we're about to go up
and you know how they have those wood
planks that you walk up it's kind of
like stairs
you should see pictures of it without
those that would there it's a slide it
is a i was going to ask is it like a
tube almost it's like well it's actually
it's rounded because the top is really
um there's like it's like a reverse it's
kind of it's a pyramid inside and
there's almost like staging um
into the ceiling yes it looks like it's
acoustically designed it's not just flat
there's actually like purposeful edges
and ridges that are symmetrical and go
it looks like it's meant for
for frequency energy acoustics something
like that i totally agree no it's not
decoration it's functional um and if you
see it without that wood there it's a
different you get a
i'll have to send you a picture after um
because like these pictures are very old
they're black and white because those
stairs have been there forever those
planks but when you see it without it
you get this but this way
the vibe i get by looking at it without
those stairs there you would think it
funneled water and um
one of the gentlemen i met um on this
the the first time i went this guy is a
brilliant so he's a president of an air
compression
company in canada and he's a brilliant
man he's like i would say high iq
very nice guy as well and he came there
you know inclined to think he's like i
think there's more to this story here
but i'm gonna i'm gonna come look and
he's very he's an inventor like mine
and um and he had some very interesting
thoughts he's like it feels like this
place or his sense is that it's meant to
keep massive amounts of energy and just
the very layout of itself and he's like
when i look at different things that we
do with compressors just air um he's
like you know he's like it's not
irrational to suggest that if air and
water have been moved through it you
could create insane
amounts of pressure and if you have
high pressure you can do anything with
it you can make that's energy itself
like even um um the titanic like all
right so that's primitive like it's a
steam engine um the whole that 50 000
tons of iron that they were pushing it
you know 20 plus miles an hour through
the ocean
um was done not only just through a
bunch of built up pressure through steam
through heat they like throwing wood in
the fire yep yeah right like in the
scene in titanic they're stoking the
fire they're
like what are you doing here
i tried to tell them to leave because it
was so hot and steamy and it's just you
know that heat and heat creating it yeah
some smart people i met on these tours
from all over the world that were there
with open minds
and like some of them were even going
there thinking well there's probably
teams with me let me just see and like
they left egypt being like
like they're like oh my god like like
something was happening here on earth it
was really impressive and like and it's
beyond you know just beyond it's like
it's something it's gone but the mystery
is there and like to some people who i
looked up to
let me just say let me speak for myself
actually i went there
to egypt and it confirmed what i was
already highly suspicious of which is
that something spectacular was happening
on earth that humans were doing amazing
things
but i'm like i need to go and look see
with my own eyes touch some things and
kind of just get a feel before i like
you know and just then i'll know and it
confirmed it whether it's the assyrian
for sure um the the sierpin with the
centertime boxes the great pyramid and
everything else i'm like okay but in the
great pyramid in the king's chamber the
frequency was really high so my opinion
is is that it was used as like
um energy centers i just think they were
energy centers i think that perhaps they
were used for healing
perhaps they were used to somehow sort
of charge up in some kind of ways even
to rebalance and you know maybe there
was some kind of maybe there was
um
i don't know communication with
other extraterrestrials maybe that's
where it happened um
because of the alignment with um orion's
belt and the pyramids and and the way
that they use the stars perhaps as sort
of like a almost like a like a direction
it's like directions it's like a map
it's like oh yeah it can be landing here
like we're here yeah ping ping like land
here come come and get us hey hey alien
overlords that dropped us off and left
us come back and get me perfect yes
perhaps i'm i'm ready although i say
that and then i walk out at night to let
the dogs out and i'm like i'm ready i'm
not ready i don't think so
like the idea the actual idea of it is
like far like if it was really gonna
happen is a little bit more scary
although i believe that there'd be
benevolent beings and they would
probably make me feel comfortable like
in the movie contact when jody foster
meets her dad on the beach and he looks
like it's her dad but it's really
actually just an alien or an
extraterrestrial and um they're like we
thought this would make it more
comfortable for you i'm sure they could
shape shift into whatever would make us
comfortable